der stillstand wird dauern
deutschland bleibt bei den anti virus
einschränkungen bis nach den ferien und
will dass die bürger auch an ostern zu
hause bleiben corona lazarett im central
park in den usa steigen kranken und
toten zahlen schnell und immer weiter an
und was macht der fußball länderspiele
europa und champions league werden
verschoben bis auf weiteres
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers dieser nachrichten
mittwoch im überblick guten abend hinein
die korona pandemie ist die größte
herausforderung für die menschheit seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg das sagt die uno
und deutschland bleibt bei den
bestehenden kontakt sperren mindestens
bis zum 19 april
das ist ein ergebnis der schaltkonferenz
der bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder heute
auch in den osterferien soll niemand
wegfahren
das große ziel die verbreitung des virus
einzudämmen
andreas huppert hat mehr dazu das
kanzleramt auch heute noch ohne seine
hausherrin angela merkel ist weiterhin
in häuslicher quarantäne
die telefonkonferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten zur corona pandemie
machte sie von zu hause aus aus dem
homeoffice einheitlich wenn nicht schon
geschehen
kontakt beschränkungen und kontaktverbot
verlängern
grundlage für diese entscheidung wie
hoch sind die neuinfektionen wirken also
die kontakt einschränkungen denn daran
bemisst sich wie lange geschäfte kinos
und kneipen geschlossen bleiben müssen
der 1920 die vierte bedeuten nicht
automatisch so waren sich alle einig
auch die bundesregierung das dort schon
wieder alles so wird wie vor den
beschränkungen sondern wir werden in
dieser zeit erst mal diskutieren wie es
weitergeht und widerstand der
medizinisch ist jetzt wo es dann vor der
tür steht die ferien beginnen ist das
traditionelle reisezeit deshalb der
appell
bleiben sie am besten so gut wie möglich
zu hause treffen sie nicht zusätzliche
menschen machen sie keine großen
ausflüge oder machen sie keine ausflüge
auch nicht innerhalb des landes wann im
land wieder normalbetrieb herrscht waren
auch kitas schulen und universitäten
wieder öffnen steht noch in den sternen
wir waren uns heute einig dass es viel
zu früh darüber jetzt eine entscheidung
zu treffen wir halten auch das
debattieren das öffentliche debattieren
darüber für nicht zielführend
ich bitte sie weiter geduldig die
beschlossenen maßnahmen zu befolgen
bund und länder sind sich einig die
strikten auflagen und die kontakt
einschränkungen gelten bis zum ende der
osterferien erstmal also der dringende
appell aus den regierungen zu hause
bleiben auch und gerade über ostern wie
das bei den menschen hier ankommt dazu
stimmen jetzt aus stuttgart und
frankfurt also das aus meiner sicht
wichtig weil man ja eigentlich dazu
beitragen kann eben das virus letztlich
nicht weiter zu verbreiten man hat ja
schon so ein bisschen erwartet und
deswegen nimmt man das glaube ich auch
noch gerne in kauf
was soll das großartig bringen meiner
meinung nach ist ein stück kontrolle der
menschen unfrei kleine familie bleibt
zusammen also und ich finde es in
ordnung
ich finds gut so da guckt man jetzt nach
vorne einen moment herrscht bleibt also
alles wie es ist aber wann wird all das
dann das nächste mal auf den prüfstand
gestellt gibt es denn dafür dann schon
einen termin schackenthal banerjee in
berlin
ja das war heute schon sehr auffällig
dass hier eigentlich keiner einen
wirklichen ausblick geben wollte und
über konkrete nächste schritte reden
wollte ob parteiübergreifend sind sich
da die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung offensichtlich einig
dass man die krise in überschaubaren
etappen managen sollte und die menschen
nicht mit kontroversen diskussionen
verunsichern sollte aber natürlich
müssen sich alle verantwortlichen
zusammensetzen und auch darüber reden
wie es nach dem 19 april bis zu dem er
die aktuelle die etappe gehen soll
weitergehen soll
da gibt es tatsächlich auch schon einen
termin und zwar den 14 april in zwei
wochen dann ist die nächste
telefonkonferenz angesetzt da wollen
sich die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung vom robert-koch-institut
darüber informieren lassen
wie die lage in sachen sachen pandemie
ist wo steht deutschland dann zu diesem
zeitpunkt und erst danach soll eine
entscheidung fallen können
einer hat ja heute schon mal wasser in
den wein selbst für diesen termin
gegossen das war der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder wir haben
ihnen eben auch gehört er hat mehrfach
betont
man sollte nicht davon ausgehen dass bei
der nächsten entscheidung dann schon
wieder alles zur normalität zurückkehren
kann
danke dir ja nach berlin
minimale kontakte also auch über ostern
hinaus das heißt für viele auch weiter
arbeiten im home office darum geht es
gleich nach uns in einem zdf spezial und
aktuelle infos finden sie außerdem
natürlich jederzeit auf unserer zdf
heute app zum beispiel mit dem corona
update am abend und dann gucken wir auch
heute auf die aktuellen zahlen zu corona
wie immer der stand heute 18 30 von
einer halben stunde danach zählt die
johns hopkins universität für
deutschland 74 1508 infizierte 821
menschen sind gestorben
wie solche daten zusammengetragen werden
und welche probleme ist dabei gibt zeigt
jetzt reif schipanski deutschland im
stillstand um entscheiden zu können
welche maßnahmen zu treffen sind oder
gelockert werden können sind
verlässliche daten nötig das problem
bisher weiß man nur wie viele menschen
positiv getestet wurden
wie viel aber tatsächlich infiziert sind
weiß man nicht die dunkelziffer könnte
fünf bis zwanzig mal höher sein
bei den todeszahlen weiß man auch nur
wie viele der opfer das virus in sich
trugen
ob sie aber am oder nur mit dem virus
gestorben sind ob das virus also der
grund für den tod war
weiß man auch nicht von an die testerei
die findet gegenwärtig so unsystematisch
statt
also ich kenne persönlich leute die mit
39 4 mehrere tage versucht haben tests
zu kriegen gescheitert sind so dass wir
tatsächlich zahlen nicht viel anfangen
können und das ist etwas was uns
wirklich belastet wir wollen hier raus
aus der situation das ist nicht ewig
haltbar
der lösungsvorschlag wie bei einer
großen umfrage müsste repräsentativ
bundesweit gemessen und getestet werden
im idealfall bis zu 5000 menschen
täglich von ihnen müsste man wissen dass
alter geschlecht wohnort also stadt oder
land mobilität das heißt mit wie vielen
menschen haben sie täglich kontakt und
ob sie vor erkrankt sind
damit ließe sich die tatsächliche
verbreitung und dynamik des virus in der
gesellschaft verlässlich abbilden können
wir uns ist glauben die gegenwärtigen
rigiden maßnahmen aufzulösen zu
erleichtern schrittweise oder auch nur
örtlich ohne wieder in die nächste welle
von infektionen einzulaufen und
schlimmstenfalls und sogenannte ping
pong effekt zu kriegen also wo steuern
wir eigentlich und dafür brauchen wir
genauso zahlen
die kosten für eine einmonatige studie
dieser art legen laut statistik experten
bei zirka einer bis anderthalb millionen
euro dann kommen wir zum
wirtschaftlichen teil der korona
shutdown wird ja für viele unternehmen
zur existenzkrise
jetzt hat sich der warenhauskonzern
karstadt kaufhof in das staatliche
schutzschirm verfahren geflüchtet das
ist eine vorstufe der insolvenz für die
gläubiger des unternehmens bedeutet das
sie müssen ihre forderungen erst einmal
zurückstellen
das management kann jetzt versuchen das
angeschlagene unternehmen zu retten
der konzern hat inzwischen staatshilfen
beantragt dort ferber in düsseldorf das
lässt aufhorchen 28.000 mitarbeiter
karstadt kaufhof geht das geld aus wie
groß ist denn die gefahr dass die
aktuell geschlossenen kaufhäuser nach
der krise gar nicht mehr aufmachen wie
groß die ist kann man derzeit nicht
sagen aber sie besteht zumindest denn
die korona krise trifft den konzern in
einer denkbar ungünstigen situation
man ist in einer restrukturierungsphase
die beiden kaufhausketten hatten sich
zusammengeschlossen um gegen den
online-handel zu bestehen und da ist
natürlich eine schließung der häuser wie
sie seit dem 18
märz faktisch herrscht nur der
lebensmittelbereich ist ja geöffnet
einfach sehr schwierig der konzern sagt
man verliere so 80 millionen euro pro
woche
und man will eben mit diesem
schutzschirm mit kurzarbeit für viele
mitarbeiter auch mit der ankündigung
jetzt keine mieten zu bezahlen irgendwie
diese krise durchstehen
zudem hat der eigentümer angekündigt man
wolle jetzt einen dreistelligen
millionenbetrag auch zur verfügung
stehen einstellen also da ist jetzt
immer noch die hoffnung da dass das
alles so gut gehen kann dort ferber zdf
düsseldorf vielen dank gerüstet sein für
eine große zahl von patienten und
gleichzeitig für alle eine versorgung
sicherstellen
das ist die große herausforderung
speziell in großstädten berlin hat heute
begonnen mit dem umbau einer messehalle
zu einem corona behandlungszentrum
mit bis zu 1000 betten ist das als
ergänzung gedacht falls die
krankenhäuser ausgelastet sind schwer
erkrankte patienten sollen aber weiter
in kliniken intensivmedizinisch versorgt
werden
bislang reichen die kapazitäten der
kliniken in deutschland aus ganz anders
ist das bei unseren nachbarn in
frankreich und in italien hier arbeiten
die kliniken in einigen regionen am
limit und darüber hinaus die beatmungs
kapazitäten reichen nicht patienten
müssen auf andere krankenhäuser verteilt
werden
in frankreich läuft heute die bisher
grösste solche aktion mit umgebauten tgv
hochgeschwindigkeitszügen
das ist eine situation in der auch die
nachbarn beistehen 85 patienten aus
frankreich und 28 aus italien bekommen
zurzeit hilfe in deutschen kliniken
susan von lojewski und sven class
berichten die intensivstation der
uniklinik mannheim
auch hier liegen seit mehr als einer
woche zwei schwer kranke patienten aus
dem elsass beide über 60 beide müssen
beatmet werden
als die anfrage der landesregierung kam
haben sie in mannheim sofort zugesagt so
lange die kapazitäten noch so vorhanden
sind wie sie derzeit vorhanden sind
zumindest in unserer region war es kein
problem insofern sehe ich derzeit
bezüglich der beiden patienten die
würden übernommen haben wirklich kein
versorgungsengpass für die bevölkerung
hier zwei bis drei wochen müssen die
kogit 19 patienten in der regel beatmet
werden
auch das müssen die kliniken mit blick
auf neue patienten ins kalkül ziehen
dazu eine zahl der vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin 57 prozent
der bei ihr registrierten intensivbetten
sind derzeit belegt mit großen
regionalen unterschieden in
norddeutschland kamen gestern ebenfalls
sechs patienten aus frankreich an
sie wurden verteilt auf die standorte
lübeck und kiel
befürchtungen dass bald keine betten
mehr für die eigene bevölkerung zur
verfügung stehen haben sie auch hier
nicht da kann ich sie beruhigen wir
haben noch deutlich weitergehende
kapazitäten wir können alle auch noch
mehr patienten aufnehmen die jetzt noch
neu kommen und im team war es
interessanterweise so dass eine große
zustimmung
wir alle waren der meinung wir müssen
den schwer betroffenen gebieten helfen
die zahl der intensivbetten hat man auch
hier aufgestockt auch deshalb kann man
nun patienten aus krisenregionen
aufnehmen wir haben hier eine
krankenhaus infrastruktur mit der wir
umgehen können und wo die welle noch
nicht ganz so angekommen ist dann ist
das glaube ich eine ethische
verpflichtung dass wir das tun sollten
noch ist die kapazität da doch sie wird
das sagen sie alle befristet und
begrenzt sein
die meisten registrierten infektionen
weltweit gibt es in den usa und die
zahlen dort steigen weiter rasant an
aktuell auf 190 1740 infizierte der
präsident hatte bisher abgewickelt und
beschwichtigt jetzt kommen dramatische
worte von donald trump er geht jetzt
davon aus dass es in den usa bis zu
240.000 tote geben könnte aus washington
berichtet ines trams hilfe für die usa
von ungewohnter seite russland bringt in
der nacht eine flugzeug ladung mit
gesichtsmasken und medizinischer
ausrüstung auf den weg präsident putin
hatte die hilfe angeboten präsident
trump nahm sie dankend an
er präsentiert bedrückende zahlen eine
dramatische kurve in amerika werden
voraussichtlich bis zu 100 oder gar 200
40.000 menschen am corona virus sterben
sofern die ausgangs und
reisebeschränkungen strikt befolgt
würden
hoffentlich werden wir bald wie die
wissenschaftler voraussagen licht am
ende des tunnels sehen aber erstmal
kommen zwei sehr sehr schmerzhafte
wochen
doch nicht alle bundesstaaten halten
sich konsequent an die einschränkungen
florida strände noch immer voll
derweil sendet der flugzeugträger
roosevelt von bram einen hilferuf rund
100 matrosen sind infiziert soziale
distanzierung hier unmöglich der
kommandant bittet per brief um
evakuierung der mannschaft zurückhaltend
die reaktion des verteidigungsministers
zunächst wollen wir versuchen das virus
einzudämmen indem der test auf das
schiff bringen und so eine ahnung
bekommen wie viele infiziert sind
new york city das epizentrum der korona
krise zelte im central park sollen die
bestehenden kliniken entlasten
mehr als 200 pfleger sind bereits selber
erkrankt auch thomas kreiling wenn es
hart auf hart kommt setze ich mein leben
ein für die patienten aber ich musste
hören dass ich dafür nicht die richtige
ausrüstung bekommen
es fehlt an schutzausrüstung und
beatmungsgeräten hier in new york und im
rest des landes
schmerzhafte wochen stehen bevor sagt
der präsident new york city erlebt die
bereits die zeitungen dort sind voller
todesanzeigen johannes hano ist für uns
in new york johannes guten abend wie ist
denn die situation zu beschreiben in der
stadt ja der new yorker gouverneur hat
sich fast flehentlich an das ganze land
gewendet er hat alle medizinisch alles
medizinische personal aus allen
bundesstaaten aufgefordert sofern sie
nicht selber in einer medizinischen
katastrophe sind sofort nach new york zu
kommen so schnell wie möglich nach new
york zu kommen
denn das krankenhaus system mit sei am
anschlag die krankenschwestern ärzte und
pfleger bräuchten dringend entlastet wie
drastisch die situation ist warum weder
klar die zeigen dass man ihr
mittlerweile dazu übergegangen ist
leichen mit dem gabelstapler in
kühllaster zu verfrachten ein bisschen
hilfe kommt jetzt aus washington
die nationale katastrophenschutzbehörde
hat gesagt sie schickt 250 rettungsauto
lanzen mit personal und 85 zusätzliche
kühllaster also das ist wird hier
dramatisch schlimme bilder aus new york
johannes hahn herzlichen dank eine
ausführliche reportage über die lage in
new york ist ein teil des auslands
journals heute abend eine spezialausgabe
um 22.30 hier im zdf
was die korona krise auf dem
arbeitsmarkt anrichten kann das zeigen
die aktuellen zahlen aus österreich
stand ende märz noch nie seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg waren dort so viele
menschen arbeitslos ein plus von sage
und schreibe 52 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat
um die virus verbreitung ein zudem
sollen die österreicher ab heute
mundschutz in supermärkten tragen die
masken werden am eingang verteilt auch
selbst genähte sind akzeptiert
österreichs regierung hat verfügt dass
spätestens ab dem 6 april einem
mundschutz pflicht in geschäften mit
mehr als 400 quadratmetern gilt
offen ist aber ob der vorrat an masken
ausreicht als kleine grippe hatte
brasiliens präsident die durch das virus
ausgelöste krankheit abgetan und von
hysterie gesprochen jetzt ändert ihre
ball szenario seinen ton das land stehe
vor der größten herausforderung dieser
zeit sagte er in einer fernsehansprache
vor allem mit blick auf die
wirtschaftlichen folgen die antwort der
brasilianer klang in vielen städten so
den 15 tag in folge protestierten sie
gegen seinen umgang mit der pandemie
auch in der türkei ist der umgang mit
der epidemie alles andere als
transparent die zahlen die die regierung
nennt sind widersprüchlich schwer
nachzuvollziehen
fest steht allerdings dass sie rasant
steigen nach angaben der
johns-hopkins-universität verdoppelt
sich die zahl der korona infektionen in
der türkei so schnell wie sonst kaum wo
auf der welt jörg brase aus istanbul die
zahlen auf der webseite des türkischen
gesundheitsministeriums sind die einzig
gültigen 13 1531 infektionen und 214
corona tote sollen es sein stand gestern
abend durch die türkische ärztekammer
meldet zweifel an
wir bekommen die richtigen zahlen und
die liegen etwas höher
die informationen die wir erhalten sind
valide weil unsere kammern in allen
provinzen organisiert sind
die opposition glaubt dass die regierung
die zahlen schön dumm panik zu
verhindern
so wurden zum beispiel für den 28 märz
landesweit offiziell 16 corona tote
gemeldet
auf der webseite der stadt istanbul
jedoch wurden am selben tag allein für
die metropole 20 19 tote aufgeführt tags
drauf waren die angaben zur todesursache
plötzlich von der seite verschwunden
natürlich dürfen die namen der toten
nicht veröffentlicht werden aber die
angabe wie viele corona opfer ist wo
gegeben hat gehört zu einer
transparenten politik nur so können wir
das virus erfolgreich bekämpfen bekämpft
werden dagegen die überbringer
schlechter nachrichten wegen angeblicher
falschmeldungen in den sozialen
netzwerken auch zu überfüllten
notaufnahmen oder massengräbern für
corona opfer wurden bereits knapp 400
ermittlungsverfahren eröffnet die
türkische regierung beschwert
unterdessen die einheit des volkes im
kampf gegen das virus und die meisten
menschen bleiben zumindest in den
großstädten tatsächlich zu hause so viel
zu diesem thema es gibt nur wenige
nachrichten heute die nichts mit dem
virus zu tun haben hier kommen zwei die
bundesregierung will den nutzern von
sozialen medien mehr rechte geben wenn
sie beleidigt oder bedroht
werden die netzwerke müssen
sicherstellen dass möglicherweise
strafbare inhalte unkompliziert gemeldet
werden können und dann begründen warum
sie die einträge löschen oder eben nicht
wenn fälle schließlich vor gericht gehen
müssen sie die daten des beschuldigten
offenlegen so hat es das bundeskabinett
heute beschlossen und dann noch einen
rekordwert bei erneuerbaren energien in
deutschland zum ersten mal wurde mehr
als die hälfte des verbrauchten stroms
bei uns ökologisch produziert von januar
bis märz waren es 52 prozent aus wind
sonne und wasserkraft
hauptgründe waren viel wind und sonne
und ein etwas geringerer stromverbrauch
die korona krise hat den fussball
spielplan komplett durcheinander
gebracht gestern hatten die clubs der
ersten und zweiten liga die spielpause
bis zum 30 april verlängert heute hat
die europäische fußball union
beschlossen die champions und die europa
league erst frühestens im sommer
fortzusetzen und die länderspiele die
eigentlich im sommer anstehen sollen
auch verschoben werden
dazu müssen noch mal reden mit markus
haben aus unserer sportredaktion markus
guten abend fangen wir mit champions
league europa league an kann denn das
klappen jetzt mit dem neuen plan
na ja das hängt natürlich erst einmal
vom weiteren verlauf der korona pandemie
ab vor allem in italien und in spanien
aber die uefa setzt ein klares signal
sagt die nationalen ligen wie die
bundesliga haben vorrang die müssen erst
einmal zu ende gespielt werden
und da niemand davon ausgeht dass in
italien oder spanien die saison bis zum
31 7 zu ende gespielt werden kann sagt
die uefa sie wollen champions league und
europa league
im juli und august ausspielen und dann
markus auf die länderspiele gucken die
werden noch weiter nach hinten geschoben
was heißt das für die nationalmannschaft
für die nationalverbände ist das schon
sehr sehr hart wie für den dfb zum
beispiel denn es gibt keine garantien ob
diese länderspiele tatsächlich
ausgetragen werden zwei klassiker gegen
spanien und italien sind schon mal auf
unbestimmte zeit verschoben jetzt zwei
weitere länderspiele und wie das alles
in 2020 noch platz haben soll das ist
eher vage und natürlich hängt da viel
geld dran
man sagt zehn millionen euro an ein
länderspiel sollte einst ausfallen also
corona trifft den fußball ziemlich hat
viele fragen auch markus herzlichen dank
für heute abend
und das noch schnell vom sport der
heilige rasen von wimbledon kann in
diesem jahr ungestört weiter wachsen
das tennis turnier ist heute abgesagt
worden
der uno generalsekretär sieht die
menschheit in ihrem größten test seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg damit haben wir
die sendung heute begonnen
er sagt auch wir werden die krise
überwinden
klar ist jeder kann dabei mitmachen
münchens taxifahrer haben diese idee bei
ihnen ist der weg zur klinik und zurück
nach hause jetzt kostenlos und zwar für
alle ärztinnen und ärzte schwestern und
pfleger also für die die gerade
unermüdlich anderen helfen das mal geht
die gratis fahrt auf kosten der
taxiunternehmen langfristig hoffen sie
auf unterstützung vom staat damit diese
geste schule macht und dann gucken wir
uns noch die lottozahlen an
und die lauten 4 15 22 39 46 48 die
superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
das wetter viel sonne und nur etwas
regen mehr dazu gleich von austin terry
22 uhr ist zeit für marietta slomka im
heute-journal jetzt gleich ein zdf
spezial mit hanna zimmermann und morgen
sind wir wieder für sie da versprochen
aber erst wo immer es geht in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der hohen
luftdruck schwindet allmählich und auch
die hochdruckbrücke über mitteleuropa
wird allmählich schwächer das reicht
aber noch für sonnenschein morgen aber
im norden deutschlands kommt neuer regen
auf in der nacht ist es trocken aber die
vielen wolken im norden die sind schon
vorhanden nach süden kaum wolken und
dort wird es dann am kältesten vor allem
südlich des mains temperaturen zwischen
minus 1 und minus sieben grad nach
norden ist es teils frostfrei mit 3 bis
5 grad
morgen also vor allem in der südhälfte
viel sonnenschein aber hier im rhein
main gebiet da kommen durchaus einige
wolken auf sonst stark bewölkt bis teils
regnerisch an der nordsee und kräftiger
west bis südwestwind temperaturen dazu
erreichen höchstwerte von sieben grad im
hessischen bergland und 14 grad im
südwesten deutschlands das ist also die
temperaturspanne schauen wir auf die
nächsten tage
am freitag gibt es einige schauer vor
allem im norden und bis nach osten in
richtung vogtland und erzgebirge sonst
im süden aber trockenes wetter bei 7 bis
13 grad am samstag dann deutlich
trockener und sonniger 8 bis 17 grad und
sonntag sogar bis 21 grad sank kommt
dann die wärme aus dem westen zu uns
damit ein schöner abend